well
should we uh should we stop down and
talk about what we're doing here we're
we're on uh uh we're not all together in
the same place
and we're gonna have to do some episodes
like this every now and then because yes
and we can always blame somebody right
like this is somebody's fault this is
who are we going to blame okay we can
blame we can blame a little bit of glenn
we could blame a little bit of megan
why can't we how can we blame that the
office isn't ready i don't know we
haven't we're moving to a new office
well
yes that is true we're moving into a new
studio and it is not ready which might
be the reason we have to do another one
of these maybe but i'm pretty excited
about it maybe we'll do another one at
rob's house because that was pretty nice
too but glenn you're in in texas glenn's
in texas yeah but to be fair to megan
glenn it's really glenn's fault because
megan has been working tirelessly to get
us from one building to another and it's
actually going to happen rather quickly
so really glenn this is all your fault
yeah
yeah yeah that's uh i'd say i'd say
that's accurate
because you wanted to support your wife
so bad
yeah it's what i get for supporting my
wife i'm i'm out here in south by
southwest uh in austin
and uh you know
it's uh i don't know if you guys have
ever been to uh south by southwest but
uh
the whole town is just a big party
uh it was crazy i've been to austin
several times and i always enjoy going
to austin but i've not i've been to so
few
like
festivals and things and i think it
would be so fun
smattering
yeah jill's movie premieres tonight so
um that'll be that'll be interesting
that'll be fun
exciting
but yes this is this is my fault
this is my fault i appreciate you taking
responsibility for that glenn
yeah
yeah man yeah although i guess you could
also say it was you know i'll take some
responsibility or some blame because
normally we do it during the week and
i'm unavailable this week so maybe it's
actually my fault
oh so it would have happened anyway
would it would have been this way anyway
i i suppose i'm also uh
i also have to take some blame because i
i you know i'm the one who's always
insisting that uh
you know we we find an office that's
sort of equidistant between the three of
us um so you know the fact that we even
had to move offices
uh i don't know i'm just trying to throw
my hat in the ring it's not really my
fault
[Music]
should we talk about this episode yeah
i watched it with my son
yeah uh
okay
how was that experience well yeah um
we've been trying to dip our toes into a
little bit he's turning 12 and we
started dipping our toes into
you know allowing him to watch some of
the episodes and we thought again having
no memory of it whatsoever we thought
maybe this one might be a fun one to get
into and there are aspects of the story
that are but then this is really where
we established dennis as a sexual
predator in in some capacity um
there's there's some of that for sure
this to me i'm like oh we don't yet know
what the show is and we're looking for
it yeah like there's some
for sure yeah super cartoonish elements
of the story which i did not enjoy no
person
yeah no we pushed we pushed it on this
one real far and i remember us talking
about this actually when we were writing
it too i remember when we were working
on this episode we were like
this is really
insane like what we're doing here and i
think
you know because we it was the first
time we we had to do 15 episodes which i
think was pretty overwhelming to us at
the time
uh well
that would be overwhelming to me now um
i don't think we had time to really
second-guess ourselves i think we just
had to press on and and make the best of
it that we could and i would actually
argue that for as cartoonish as it is it
did make me laugh uh i i was laughing a
lot um but it is ridiculous i mean we go
from just
you know bar owners and you guys are
going clothing shopping to like running
a full-on sweatshop by the end where you
have a steam whistle
you know and uh and we've hired a bunch
of uh eastern european uh knock worst
smelling women to to to so close for us
i mean it's it's it's that opening i
think like
there was
so the opening scene is so great and i
remember yeah so distinctly first of all
judy greer is fantastic and we knew her
from arrested development
right that's where we knew her from and
um and so i remember on that day that
was not scripted that charlotte
charlie has all the hats and all the
clothes on and he didn't tell anybody he
was doing it i i distinctly remember and
it was a reveal
and so
d d walks over and the camera just pans
over charlie's full-on laughing or at
least smiling i remember being behind
the monitors and laughing yeah yeah
that's what i'm sure i was just doing
for you guys being like all right let's
let me see if i can throw them off here
and
it's the stat it's the stack of hats and
the the stack of hats
and the fact that you found a hoodie
that could actually yeah
most hoodies wouldn't most hoodies
wouldn't go over that many hats i don't
know really who this character is but
he's in my mind from somewhere in my
childhood but like do you remember at
the great gazoo
he was like a cartoon character
kind of like the martian and warner
brothers big bunnies thing but like
i don't know some big brain like alien
guy
and uh i was going for a great kazoo
well i i definitely remember being in a
store and and early on and even still to
this day but certainly early on we would
barely be able to afford to shoot to
shut a store we definitely couldn't shut
a store down so the store would be like
okay you guys can shoot here but we're
going to keep it open
and then
it would just be like rando people
walking in and being like what's going
on in the middle of a take and we would
be like we're making a show
and and and that's because that's all we
could afford and so we would be kind of
like huddled up in the side of
of of a clothing store and people would
just be walking by just doing just
shopping going about their day i think
we just didn't have any money and
everybody was just doing the best they
could like locations was like how much
is my budget oh okay well they walk in
they're like i'll give you 50 bucks to
let us shoot here and the owners are
like sure but we're staying open yeah
yeah yeah and they're like i don't think
the guys think and they're like this
isn't one of those shows where that
matters you know what i mean yeah yeah
that's right it really the production
value and have you seen this show it
looks like [ __ ] it does not matter there
will be people looking directly into the
camera like that's fine the guys don't
really care about that that that is
often that you go around and you're
scouting locations and they're like okay
it's one it's one price to buy the whole
thing out which is usually pretty
expensive it's another price to shoot in
here but we're staying open but you've
got to kind of stay out of our workspace
you got to like find a corner to shoot
in and i think we did a lot of option b
deals
uh and probably still do you know
uh but yeah but but anyway so the this
the dennis carr i mean you're so funny
in this glenn like that and and it
starts the peak it starts with you
haven't begun to peak yet
which
that's endured yeah i i mean i i can see
i can see myself as a as an actor and i
do remember and i think we have talked
about this but like i do remember that
season three really was the year where
i feel like i found the character i mean
it took i mean
not that it wasn't there before but like
i really felt like i was
as an actor just sort of like letting
myself be a little bit more insane and
crazy and unhinged and
just weird just making weird choices and
just kind of doing whatever i thought
was was funny
um and taking a risk that other people
would find it funny too but um
uh i i can see that also in this episode
rob like i i i can see myself like just
trying on like let's just see
how despicable and egotistical and awful
and narcissistic and predatory
can we make this character and still
have it be funny it's just like how far
can i push this guy
and you do see a lot of that um in in
the episode and ironically that is it
that you you're starting to see really
who the character becomes who he really
went on on a run on and i i feel like i
can't remember specifically but i think
we probably had some debate over whether
or not we could do this for your
character or in general but you have the
funny run of like words like no or stop
or don't have never worked on me and i
feel like i remember
uh i remember some like some debate
about it but i don't i don't remember
like if you you might have been
uncomfortable with it definitely we
definitely all were but we kept i
remember just kept saying
yes but if we're going to do the thing
let's do the thing so if we're going to
if we're going to suggest that these are
the worst people on the planet and
that's the joke then let's just go all
the way into it and how can we do that
in every in every which way
yeah it's it's uh i i remember that too
charlie as a matter of fact i it'd be
interesting to maybe go back and try and
find the original shooting script of
that because i think a lot of that stuff
maybe wasn't even in the script i think
that was stuff that we were
like messing around with on the day
and
yeah i think there was a lot of improv
happening there um
around that section um
and i remember us i i remember us like
laughing a lot but also thinking like
also all of us being very
uncomfortable but in a way that we were
like i think it's i think we should push
through this discomfort because
it is making us laugh and we are
portraying this awful awful human being
you know and a certain mentality that
again this is what our show is that is a
mentality that really does exist you
know what i mean it's like this
misconception of what it means to be a
confident winner it's so despicable to
us the the three of us and all of us as
people that it was well but then we have
we have judy's character a saying over
and over and including that in that one
scene with the model and then um with
ingrid nelson where they're straight up
saying you are a bad person you are a
piece of [ __ ] like
and and that's they're the mirror to the
audience right the audience is looking
at that and saying oh yes the show is
recognizing that this behavior is
terrible and my 11 year old is watching
it and he's and he's like dennis is
insane right and i'm like yes and he's
like he's he's the bad guy in the story
and i'm like yes okay so the 12 year old
gets it that's a good sign i can i speak
for all women why i think it works
at least for me why i why i like it it's
the comment like it's the combination of
that um rant about words like no and
stop and the winners thing and also
dennis's obsession with the body shape
of this woman and it all comes from a
place for me of feeling like someone in
his past maybe his parents maybe his
coaches
someone fed him these like messages
about what what is good and what it
takes to succeed
and that is what he's like regurgitating
and so to me like the whole thing as a
whole works almost as like
being about toxic masculinity and the
way that like it's ingrained as as you
cannot fail in this thing this woman
can't reject you and also having judy
there to be like i see a woman an
uncomfortable confused woman stuffed
into a dress like that is always about
some kind of mania with us like i i feel
like we really stumbled on like
okay if these characters are borderline
maniacal with with their
insecurities really you know uh then it
it starts to become funny but unless it
is yeah he kicked down he kicked down
is that when we started the kicking
indoor jokes because that that we we did
a bunch of kicking indoors
where we're like you kicked it in and we
revealed it was kicked in have you guys
ever kicked in a door we had a door in
in brooklyn that we had to kick in one
time it was surprisingly easy
what do you mean what do you mean you
actually kicked in a door is what you're
saying yes our door to our my door to my
our apartment we got locked out of it
and we kept calling the
the building manager and he wasn't
around and we were like there's no way
to get into this door so
and i think somebody tried to like jump
into it and that doesn't work because it
hurts your shoulder but if you just back
up
and kick the [ __ ] kick the door at the
hinge what happens it doesn't break the
lock it just breaks the door hinge
rather easily
oh now again i this is probably a pr i
don't know when this building was built
it was a piece of [ __ ] so i'm sure doors
are much more reinforced now but it was
surprisingly easy oh that's kind of
that's kind of fun well yeah i mean we
do we do try to kick in the door uh
marked private yeah
in the uh the korea episode battering
ram
to it
we also uh we also bat uh uh we actually
do battering ram a door open in season
five in um the episode where we're the
mortgage crisis episode we we use an
actual battery ram
just bash through that door do you guys
remember that i was gonna say i had a
buddy in college uh we were at this um
we were at like someone's house party
and there was a big snowstorm
and uh this was pre-cell phones right so
he had left a party comes back like
hours later the party's like guys bad
news man somebody broke into our
apartment
um but i like i got home right when the
guy had broken in and he like scrambled
out uh the window or something and we're
like oh [ __ ]
and you saw the door was all kicked in
and everything and we're like man oh
glad you got here in time
um
then you know it's like late at night
and i kind of was still up and and the
buddy who saw the guy had gone to sleep
and i started thinking about a story
thinking about it i'm like
and i go and i
grab this dude's shoe
and it perfectly matches the shoe brand
and the door
and what had happened was he was just so
hammered and he lost his key
that he
that that he kicked the door in and came
up with a whole
crazy story instead of just being like
instead of going all the way back to the
party and snowstorm and getting someone
else's key but we busted him on it yeah
i fixed the door
wow so you guys have uh both have
kicking indoors stories i don't i don't
have any kicking indoors probably good
that's not right in a door
it always sounded fun to me though it's
one of those things like god that that
sounds you know there's like a handful
of things that always sounded kind of
interesting to me that i always wanted
to test the theory of like when i was a
kid i was always like
get like kicking a door down like what
how do i do this why don't we in our new
studio we just commit to whatever the
cost is to repair a door okay
and then we just give you your dream
buddy this is hollywood
you know like you can do whatever you
want
let's lock a door let's find a door that
you can kick in and we'll put it on the
podcast and and you can talk about your
experience of kicking the door in and
how you felt how you felt before how it
changed you i think
yeah
well no let me throw this out there
because i've got a list of things
but you know it's not just the door
there's there's like you want to kick in
no
no no no no a whole list of things that
do
things that i've that i've always seen
that i saw in movies a lot as a kid that
i always wanted to uh you know check out
like
one of them's kicking at a door now
that's an easy one to set up this next
one i'm about to name is is uh would not
be so easy
uh kick but by the way we should do that
uh because i really would like to do
that means a lot to me that you would
spend the money on a door
or at least you know split split split
it you know we'll split it yeah we'll
split the door
it depends on the door right if it's
like one of those like you know like
within a building from one room to
another sure but if we're talking about
from the outside of a building into a
building those are i think i think we
start with an inside door yeah okay well
glenn what else is on that list glenn
let's see if we can get like a checklist
of things that glenn's always wanted to
do and then we can do them we can we can
create and provide the environment for
you to achieve your dreams okay well
i don't know that we could do this next
one but
i've always wanted to know what it was
like to actually sink in quicksand
[Laughter]
where can we get some quicksand i feel
like quicksand was portrayed and
portrayed in so many different movies
like when we were kids growing up like i
mean most famously you know like there
was the there's the scene in the
neverending story of course where the
where the horse sinks that's that was
awful because that apparently that horse
really died
uh you guys know that right
that horse that that horse actor
that horse
that horse in that in that real scene
actually died
no
they couldn't get it out they couldn't
retrieve it yeah yeah look it up megan
uh please god i hope that's not
they're like they're like okay and cut
uh great job let's get the horse and uh
uh did you say get did you say get the
horse
no no no no no
oh sorry you wanted to take the horse
okay all right this was your course
there's no oh no
that is so sad and the whole point of
the scene right was that that the horse
didn't believe anymore and and and
the kids begged me hold on i'm i'm
seeing online that that's uh that's uh
not true
which i i'm so glad because i was i'm so
happy i'm so traumatized by that scene
fake that
that so entertainment weekly if you
believe that says the horse didn't
really die despite what's been said
throughout the years
we had two identical white horses and it
was shot over a few weeks that that
scene
i don't know i mean i was at an
entertainment weekly party last night i
don't know if i trust those that's uh
that sounds like a dead horse cover-up
and then of course there's the quicksand
scene in the princess bride
yeah that's right in the fire swamp
in the fire swamp uh i do believe there
are other quicksand uh there there was
like an obsession with quicksand we were
successful lots of cartoons like bugs
bunny cartoon kind of things
yeah yeah uh just i mean
we did a version of it this season in
sunny on with the bog
that's right the version yeah i was very
happy about that by the way i was also
very happy that i wasn't the person who
had to do it
uh when we get to that episode we should
have caitlyn tell the story of of uh of
shooting that scene because her story of
her experience of actually sinking in
that and that in that mud was is so
funny and so messed up yeah she she has
done a lot of things for the physical
things to her body for the sake of
comedy and uh that is one of the more
upsetting ones
meg can you see if quicksand does exist
somewhere on this yeah
i was there for that i was there for
that shooter and i asked her to go under
i was like
if you could it'd be great if you could
go under for one
and she did but it wasn't even the i
don't even think that was the worst part
of it uh it sounded like it was going up
her pants and
like bubbles were going up her pants and
she thought that she thought she thought
they were like little creatures crawling
up her hands but it was just bubbles and
she didn't she was like she was like but
i don't she didn't want to stop the take
because she was like if i
you know i don't want to be doing this
yeah yeah then you got to redo it then
you got to redo it and she's like there
i think there's little creatures like
crawling up inside my body right now and
and and and but she was like but we got
to get this like that
yeah she's a i mean like that kudos to
her wait so meg where is their where's
their quicksand in this world so
quicksand really does exist and it's
basically when
sand is so small and fine and it mixes
with water but what i'm seeing is that
you can't really drown in it in the way
that they portray in movies it's not
sucking you down into it but quicksand
is a phenomenon that can happen when
water reduces the friction of like very
fine sand now if somebody were to give
you a paralytic you know as a paralytic
a paralyzing drug of some kind and pop
you on some quicksand and just slowly
let you sink that's pretty [ __ ]
diabolical
[Laughter]
all right what else what else do you
want to do and what else sir what are
your dreams
well this one this one i've actually
gotten to do uh and i and i have to say
i was very excited about it um
the first i've had i've gotten to do
this a few times and i don't know if you
guys have ever played this game
it's so stupid
sorry uh okay so the first time i got to
do this was when i when i got my wisdom
teeth taken out um because i'd never had
any kind of surgery prior to that and
you know they were gonna the guy was
like okay so here's here's what we're
gonna do i'm gonna put an iv in you
and i'm going to have you count down
from 20 or something like that or maybe
it was 10. i don't remember um and
you know then you're gonna you're gonna
go you're gonna go night night and i was
like oh i've seen this in like james
bond movies where like they you know
they give like the hero a drug and he's
gotta try to stay awake
as long as he possibly can because if he
falls asleep he's dead you know uh so i
thought like ooh i wonder how long if i
really really put some effort into this
i wonder how long i can stay
awake right so he puts the needle in and
i'm like okay here we go
10.
yeah yeah exactly and then you're out i
just like i think i made a direct thing
happen
where i did the same thing i was like
i'm going to try and stay awake i was
like what i asked the guy like the
anesthesiologist how long has someone
been able to stay like what's the number
that they said you did this too you did
the same exact thing i've done it twice
and two different anesthesiologists and
yeah same and same and both both times
but more specifically the first time
the guy was like what do you mean i'm
like what number do do you think i can
make it to if i'm counting down he goes
what number do you want to get to and i
said i don't i don't know like six he
goes all right then i'll put you out on
six and i go well no i mean maybe i want
to do four he's like he's like then i'll
put you out on four and i'm like no no i
want to try and get there you try to put
me out on 10. he goes buddy if i try to
put you out on town you'll go out on 10.
you'll go out whenever i tell you to go
out and i was like okay fine so i go 10.
[Laughter]
i know there are other things that are
on that list and i actually think i
i think i actually think i have that
list somewhere and the reason i have it
is because uh
i think i've maybe tried to pitch it
uh for the show before where our
characters
actually want to experience these things
that they that they saw in 80s movies is
get blown to safety one of them that's
such a great 80s movie i think where
like the explosion happens on you and
then you're like rocketed into like a
like a body of water yeah the rock is a
famous one like uh yeah the rock where
he where he's like ah and it just like
gets blown in the water it's like thank
god that i got blown to safety to be
clear that you're talking about the rock
the the michael bay joint not the
michael bay movie not the although i
would say probably the actor the rock
has also been blown to safety he's
probably been blown to safety a few
times too long
i can't yeah and if he hasn't i'm sure
it's in his next contract because he's
like when do i get to be blown to safety
those are all the movies i grew up with
because he grew up with the same movies
we did
yeah he wants to be blown to safety just
like all of us do
um you know without somehow
i guess the trick to being blown to
safety really is
a how flexible is your spine right
because you're gonna
you know what i mean when it hits you
yeah you get you know depending on if
it's from the front of the back but
either way your spine's gonna go like
that okay so that's number one number
two is what's your tolerance for
shrapnel
yeah that's right that's right well you
got to know because the shrapnel
hopefully is blowing around you but not
directly into you
yeah yeah you got a couple pieces in
here is there something soft you can
land into when you're blown to bits
that's right is there right is there a
mattress truck going by just as you get
yeah yeah truck full of chicken feathers
or like
you know
you know like is there a swimming pool
somewhere is ideal and the explosion
because you might you might you might be
on fire and the the pool will put you
out right i mean
yeah i think that's the idea your body
can defy the laws of physics because
that is what's happening right in that
in that
surviving the concussive force that is
so strong it can blow your body
somewhere else but isn't
isn't decimating this the flesh
on your uh on your corpus yeah well the
on your corpus
is that did you is that right is that
did you use that word properly
all right glenn what do you got what do
you got one of them is just like
getting chloroformed oh you know having
somebody put the yeah put a chloroform
over that's now that's something we
could do well that's probably that's
something i mean that's essentially
propofol isn't it like it's the i don't
know how am i going to explain these
expenses
i would be concerned about the
chloroform because there's a there's a a
chance either person doesn't come come
out and then yeah yeah so you can so the
only way that works is if you chloroform
yourself
because i don't want to be on the hook
for that
i'm not going to be a part of this
chloroforming each other according to
the movies you got to pour it on the
cloth and you've got to get it around
the guy's mouth
and and you've got to hold it there for
a while like it doesn't happen instantly
you got to get it
i'm glad you're saying he he he's going
to struggle it's a he on he you know
yeah you know what yeah this is a he on
he in my in my mind and and you know
what i'm fantastic i'm way more i'm way
more glad
it's good that it's it's something i
said
it is good
it's good yeah but it worries me it
worries me a little
[Laughter]
yeah well
this this man this man doesn't have a
mustache because the mustache but i like
to believe i can count
i can fight it off the way that i could
not as not as well as i could fight off
the propofol but i could fight off the
chloroform i think i i think we should
find out how toxic it is right like we
don't want to do any permanent damage
here
uh but uh if if we're looking at a
situation where it's not that bad
uh for you uh i'll do that i'll do that
certainly sounds like a good time if we
find out that it's really not a huge
deal to knock someone out with a
a noxious uh chemical gas
um then i i would do that where you try
to chloroform me and i try to fight it
off
so all of our fantasies get to come true
what does that mean you try to fight it
off do you get to physically try to
fight glamour okay because that's a big
part okay not being smart
okay the guy put the rag over my mouth
i'm gonna kick backwards try to catch
his nuts and scramble out of this really
quick you know yeah versus like i'm
gonna try to not let the chemical yeah
fair i i would say we could start we can
start in a very specific position which
is
which i have to let him get it to my
face
and then no i think rob if you really
want to do this we have to see that it's
safe and then we have to not let you
know when glenn's going to go in front
of you
that's stuff that's that's the real test
and if he starts doing it yeah can he do
it quick enough to knock you out i got
to be ready for it at any at any time
i don't want to be a part of this no
that's probably fair absolutely fair i
don't blame you we we we definitely
shouldn't do it but uh but we should
definitely research we not do it we
shouldn't let people in general know
that it's something that can or cannot
be done right like this
is from movies we're pulling from from
movies from the past you know 30 years
yeah but somebody out there is listening
to our podcast being like wait oh really
look
that that's like when you watch those
commercials and there's somebody driving
a truck off the top of a building and
crashing into the ground and then they
have to put the war the disclaimer
underneath it do not attempt i mean is
that where we are as a [ __ ] culture
that we just have to cater to every dumb
dumb on the planet and be like well hey
just fyi this isn't real and you
shouldn't do this [ __ ] off
like where's the pr there's no no
personal responsibility whatsoever get
out of here yeah but it is but it is
real we're talking about really doing it
to each other
yes
fictionally doing it but yeah we're
we're talking about how well you can
fight it and how well it works you know
we're giving people ideas right and how
much fun it is and how much fun it is to
perform that experiment yeah yeah well
so we should just suggest that we are
professionals right and and like you
should not try this at home because we
are professionals leave it to the
professionals guys
[Music]
i would like to based on based on every
movie i've ever seen in my entire life i
just want to watch somebody
get
knocked unconscious with one punch that
seems to happen in movies all the time
i've seen it in the ufc
i've seen it in professional fighters of
course but i've never seen that in
person and i've certainly never seen
that like done to multiple people where
you know like in a movie you'll watch
somebody jean-claude van damme or
[ __ ] stevenson just knock out like
eight guys in a row
and i've asked some of my ufc friends
some like real scary people who can
fight like hey how would you handle
three guys
and the answer is always the same run as
fast as you can and those are like the
the toughest guys i like on the planet
earth well i you you guys have all seen
uh those those great videos of uh six
foot five steven seagal like just
throwing little five foot dudes around
around the room like
that [ __ ] is so weird like i it does
look amazing like it and it like it you
know and he just he looks like he's half
asleep while he's doing it he's just
like
and the guy just goes flying and he's
just like he's just like doing this and
they're just like all just like doing
flips and falling all over the place
like and he's just like he barely has
his [ __ ] eyes open you know and he's
just doing
you know that's some [ __ ] like yeah just
flailing his hands around like i can't
tell if that guy is completely [ __ ]
badass or just totally full of [ __ ] or
some combination of the two
i really can't i cause because it looks
good you know what i mean like if any if
nothing else he's a good dancer you know
what i mean he's a cool looking well
there's a famous story about steven
seagal that uh in the in the martial
arts world where he was famous for
beating up stunned guys and like herding
stunt guys but not and not because the
the stunt guys are there to perform the
stunts and you're supposed to do that in
a safe manner and he was very famous for
for like really like getting getting
guys hurt and so there's one stunt
coordinator who was a legend in the
martial arts world uh who's named jean
labelle and that he was uh his nickname
was judo jean yeah and there's a famous
story where judo jean where stephen says
to judo jean you you could never choke
me out
because you could never get a hold of me
and he was like well i believe i could
and steven's like okay well let's see
you try and so stephen goes after him
and judo jingle bell chokes him out
right in the middle of the set and then
he wakes up
and then it's like well that was
[ __ ] you know you you just gra you
can't do it again and he did it again
and then while steven scala was
unconscious he [ __ ] himself
and so he [ __ ] himself
and woke up now there are people who
swear
that they were there in the room and saw
it and smelled it
and it was very clear that stephen's
golf had [ __ ] himself while he was
unconscious
i choose to believe that that happened
yeah
i want to know what else is on glenn's
list
like we've only
been in quicksand and chloroform what
else you got
yeah the the other one the other one uh
is uh
cutting open a huge bag of cocaine and
testing it on your gums
you know with like a knife yeah yeah
yeah i always found that like i i'm
here's here's how my brain works right
whenever i see that in a movie you know
the guy there's like a big tightly
packed thing of cocaine
and a guy takes a knife and he just then
he cuts into it and then he puts a
little on the tip of the knife you know
and he either snorts it or he or he dips
his finger in he goes like that first of
all my first thought is like
my first thought is like
well now that bag of cocaine that's
gonna be a mess
there's a giant hole in that thing like
you know what i mean like i'm like [ __ ]
now is somebody gonna tape that up or
something like that i was like hey i
don't know why that but that's where
mine bring extra tape i don't want this
to spill everywhere well you gotta get
into it you gotta get into it somehow
yeah yeah i guess you're right if you
really need to test it on the spot uh
which i mean i think it's if you've got
just like a giant crate and it's all
filled with tightly packaged
things of white powder
you know you're not it's not baking soda
you know what i'm saying it's not a
[ __ ] arm and hammer truck it's
[ __ ] cocaine okay you you probably
don't need to taste it it does feel like
there were so many traps like from
growing up like a quicksand chloroform
testing the cocaine on the gums that are
they still in
there's so many movies now i guess it's
not the same for a kid growing up right
well no because now there's more there's
more uh women making movies so that that
[ __ ] that changed a lot of things
i got to do a movie thing actually um
because of rob i got to drive a tank
over a car wait wait wait wait wait what
so i was in vegas with my husband
we were doing a road trip and
i texted rob because i was like oh my
god my husband's taking me to this gun
range and because he wanted to shoot a
bunch of world war ii era guns because
he's like a history nut and he just
wanted to like test out some of these
old machine guns and stuff
and i was like this place is so wild
they have this like experience here
where you can drive a tank over a car
and then
so i just like text him that and then i
was sitting there waiting for my
husband's like appointment and a guy
comes out and he's like is there megan
around here because somebody's on the
phone wanting to like get you this
tank experience
so he he called them and like signed me
up for it and they put me in a tank and
they have these like beater cars and i
got to like push the controls forward
and like drive a tank over a car and
like it blew out all the windows it was
awesome it was like one of the coolest
things i've ever done in my whole life
wow
that if i if i thought of it that
definitely would have gone on my list
well well what about from yeah i think
for me it wouldn't be a tank but it
would be um a monster truck
what was the what was the big monster
truck when we were kids yeah there was
one big buck bigfoot
man imagine driving bigfoot over like
yeah oh like a series of like 10 cars
have you guys been to a monster truck
rally it's super fun
yeah they are fun it's louder [ __ ] my i
took my i took my uh my oldest son to
one when he was like three years old and
he he did he was too much for him he was
like
yeah it's kind of a lot for the kids
yeah well actually once he had that
actually once again
it's also cool like in the lobby they
they hand it
yeah and they they they look like big
truck tires which is kind of cool you
know they may look like uh like and they
realize like a monster truck thing uh
once he put those on he was he was fine
it was it was
crazy crazy loud like he was he didn't
he was [ __ ] scared man it was like
you know and all these like people like
like it was
is just straight on gratuitous sex
scenes you don't see that as often where
they'll just take a break
and this was just fully accepted and and
beloved uh especially by you know 12 13
year old boys who didn't have access to
the internet um and
there would just be a movie
action movie or whatever and then three
quarters of the way through it it would
just stop and then you would just watch
two people [ __ ]
in like a very sensual way that had
nothing to do with the story and it
didn't matter and then they would then
then they would just move on with the
movie and you don't see that as often
i don't think i feel like it's moved to
hbo like
series like a lot of you know
banging and hbo sure but like if you're
talking about a show like euphoria or or
shows that like revolve specifically
around that
that being a part of the show as opposed
to just
ran just a random scene
of well now we're gonna stop everything
down to make love
and then we're gonna yeah and then we're
gonna pick the story back yeah
it seemed more out of out of the story
yeah totally
that definitely seems like the the
product of of men running hollywood like
that that's that is definitely a
byproduct of that i'd like
i mean maybe i'm wrong i don't know but
uh i'm i'm glad that the even
when i was at a young and
you know a more impressionable age i
found those scenes uncomfortable i was
like oh wow
i don't know i love i loved it it was
like that was an opportunity because we
didn't well we didn't have access to
pornography so it was like that was the
closest thing you could ever see to like
a woman's body in
and i don't know and and then and then
they would i'm thinking of like top gun
remember top gun in fact i think we did
a parody of it on sunny where it was
just like this movie about like yeah
yeah with your wife but with my lighter
jets
yeah that's the thing see that's the
difference between old hollywood and new
hollywood we we do a love scene like
that and we have dennis in it and we
cast your wife because we felt like that
would be the most appropriate way to do
it as opposed to just bringing in an act
an actor that you would then
have this wild wildly needless needless
sex scene but then also that yeah but
are we better off as a society or or
like you know are we not getting that
out of our are we just past and furious
now and would we have been fast furious
and [ __ ] but now we're just oh wait
does
it furious i don't see those movies do
they have do they have sexy they gotta
have sex scenes in them right
i don't think so
no the eroticism is handled by the the
the
the fastness and the furiousness of the
muscular men that are performing the
tasks that are are needed of them you
know what i mean like
it's all it's all very sexual by the way
it's just not in the way that it used to
be yeah what was the what was the first
movie you guys saw what was the first
movie i can remember the very first
pair of breasts that i had ever seen and
it was in a movie oh wow that's a good
question right what were the first uh
was it was it
mine too no but it but that was around
the same time that might have
that might have been one of my first
either that or lethal weapon that
firstly the weapon
one of those
yeah
i i megan i think mine might be the same
as yours i think although weirdly i
think i saw airplane two
before i saw airplane one i don't know
how that happened but uh airplane two is
also really really funny
uh and they do the same gratuitous like
uh you know women walking through the
metal detector with you know completely
nude and then like you know some dude
comes through like
some dude comes through like just armed
to the teeth with like machine guns and
[ __ ] and he puts them through the thing
they let him through and then they grab
some some innocent old lady and throw
her up against the wall and start
risking
police at police at least that's part of
a gag
police academy it's not the joke is the
cop who's the uh a person of authority
doesn't he like pour something on the
women's backs who are
sunbathing and then they just get up
and expose themselves like i mean again
we parodied that whole
kind of like ski movie slash yeah
probably romp
porkies
the first movie i ever saw revenge of
the nerds
revenge of the nerds was full nudity
sure
and and rape
and right oh yes right yeah yeah just a
little bit non-conceptual sex uh did you
ever see the movie just one of the guys
that was the phone
and then her best friend she's falling
in love with her best friend who thinks
that he this is his bud
and then slowly but surely she then
tells him
i'm a woman and he says no you're not
that's impossible
and then to prove it she rips off her
shirt
and my mind
exploded yeah she unwraps doesn't she
unwrap didn't she have she did but for
the moment of exposure she just had her
shirt on and just like ripped it open
and i
oh jesus like hulk hogan and i was
watching it with bob bateman and we were
like rewind one pause pause pause that
was the thing right you had to pause it
you had to pause it and you had to get
because sometimes the scan lines
you know would be there like covering up
and you're like ah damn it you
press play pause it again try to get
those scan lines away from the boobies
[Laughter]
oh guys we got we got to end this
because uh i i've got stuff to do all
right guys i've got a plan for today
it's 11 30. what i'm gonna do is i've
got a plan to watch
um to watch two movies today the my plan
is to watch uh charlie your movie or
amazon movie and then i'm gonna go watch
jill's documentary that's the plan for
the day yeah we're gonna go do that oh
you sweet sweet man that's gonna be
enjoyable
that's that's
that is gonna be enjoyable those are
they're they're both i'll be i'll let
you know i'll let you know
any boobies in any of those
i take my
but there's no there's no there's no
booties all right well you have
yours are boobies okay
you